And from my blood
come the prince that was promised and
his will be the song of ice and fire
Welcome back everyone i've been getting a lot
of requests for a house of the dragon video on
the white walkers and the night king because of
what's happening during this part of the timeline
and all the references that the show has made
to them in the trailers and the episodes so far
into what happened during the events of game of
thrones later in the timeline who knew about the
white walkers throughout the timeline did a lot of
people know or was it just the kings of westeros
at any given time so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel i'm doing videos
for all the episodes just like i did for the main
game of thrones series be sure to subscribe to get
them we're also doing a giveaway for hbo max
subscriptions all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and post all your theories
in the comments below careful for spoilers
from everything in the trailers and everything
that's happened on the show so far but there were
a couple long night references between the events
of episode 1 and the last big trailer that we got
here where we see renera actually reading from a
book that contains aegon the conqueror's prophecy
of a song of ice and fire you also remember that
at the end of the main show samwell wrote that
book and they called it a song of ice and fire
that was obviously meant to be a reference to
george rr martin's name for the entire series the
song of ice and fire novels for the main series
that they adapted for the game of thrones show the
difference with aegon's prophecy that he called a
song of ice and fire is that the prophecy was
just about the prince who was promised in the
long night itself just those two specific things
like as she reads from the book she says from my
blood will come the prince who was promised but
the way the book reads it sounds like it was
written by aegon himself autobiographically and
then they just passed it on from king to king and
when viserys became king he was the fifth king of
westeros at that time and it's only been a little
over 100 years since aegon's conquest so like
not that much time has passed so that means that
aegon would have only told his direct successor
amy's that was his son that became the next king
also maegor one of his other children with his
other sister wife became king after that briefly
he might have learned that after any's his
son jiharis became king he obviously learned
and then told viserys when he became the next heir
but the whole idea is that a bunch of jaehaerys's
children were male and were heirs at any given
time and they would have also probably found
out about it too but they all died untimely devs
probably before they were able to tell a bunch of
other people about the prophecy because supposedly
you're only supposed to tell it to the next
heir that's why viserys waited until now to reveal
to ranira because he officially named her heir
so it wasn't like the targaryen heirs at
any given time throughout the timeline we're
running around telling the prophecy to anybody
that will listen to it which is also why we're
just finding out about it now because it had been
kept secret in the book that actually chronicles
the events they're adapting for the show the fire
and blood book was written by maesters and taken
from accounts from the court fool called mushroom
and obviously they wouldn't have known about the
prophecy because it was kept secret and during
the events of game of thrones like during the
actual game of thrones book and the song of ice
and fire main novels there were only a couple
of characters thinking about the actual prophecy
and they're people like melisandre who don't come
from the line of succession now melisandre's like
400 years old so she's actually alive during the
events on house of the dragon right now she's
a follower of the red god so clearly it's not
only the targaryens that are having visions of
the potential coming long night aegon just had
his own dragon dream like his own version of a
vision like daenerys had visions of the house the
undying dragon dreams about the future so having
those visions of the long night weren't exclusive
to aegon the conqueror in daenerys itches that
if it's a secret that's passed from king to air
you have to remember that there was robert's
rebellion and rhaegar targaryen might not have
told robert baratheon when they fought at the
trident rhaegar was the official heir of the
mad king so the mad king would have told him at
some point it's been well documented that rhaegar
was obsessed with prophecy for most of his early
life and then eventually he met leona stark fell
in love with her and then believed jon snow was
the prince who was promised but for a brief period
rhaegar thought that he was going to be the prince
who was promised i think that was probably until
the events of him falling in love with lyanna in
the night of the laughing tree the great tourney
and then them getting married secretly after he
annulled his first marriage like oh it's not me
it's going to be this kid that we're going to
have together so there is like a brief period
during the story where jon snow daenerys don't
know about it because robert baratheon didn't
learn the prophecy and obviously he doesn't care
about daenerys and he doesn't know that jon snow
is the heir and even if he did know that jon snow
was rhaegar's son he wouldn't be able to tell him
because he didn't know the prophecy he didn't
learn it from rhaegar and talk about really old
people on game of thrones a lot of you asking
about the three-eyed raven the three-eyed raven
that we met during the events of game of thrones
wasn't actually born till well after the events
of the dance of the dragon so i don't expect to
see him be born on this series in the way george
r martin explains it when each new targaryen
king would learn the prophecy nobody actually
knew when the long night would happen so each
new king thought it was right around the corner
and was kind of paranoid about it on the dl in the
background while things actually went pretty crazy
after the reign of aegon the conqueror it was
until jaeherys that the realm experienced a period
of peace for about 50 plus years like it was
pretty crazy before jiharis took the iron throne
so while that stuff is going on you also have each
new king also being completely preoccupied and
obsessed with white walkers you kind of get that
vibe from viserys here like there's a lot of stuff
that he's worried about like he wants to keep
peace in the realm because there's been so much
peace for the past 50 years he wants to keep the
good times rolling but also on the dl he's been
obsessed obsessed with white walkers like he's got
that crazy look in his eye when he forces rene to
promise me rhaenyra you have to be vigilant about
this a lot of you also now asking if the mad king
for instance when he was saying burn them all
was he actually talking about white walkers
where's my sister
and if maegor the cruel was so cruel was he also
really worried about white walkers was that one
of the things that helped drive him a little bit
crazy it's totally possible especially the moment
with the mad king now it just has a little more
added context like when he said burn them all he
was probably also talking about the white walkers
but he legit had gone mad so he actually was
basically saying use wildfire to burn everything
like all the people and the white walkers at the
same time so explaining what was going on with
the night king and the white walkers during the
events of house of the dragon like a lot of people
wondered will we see them during the events of
this show when we pick up in season one it's meant
to be like a little over 100 years since aegon
conquered the seven kingdoms at that time the wall
had existed in the universe of the show for about
800 years they compressed the timeline for the
show in the books it's like 10 000 to 8 000 years
ago on the show it's more like 800 to a thousand
years ago but right after that first long night
the wall is built the night's watch is created
and on the show the actor playing the night king
was the same one that the children of the forest
turned into the night king a thousand years ago
implying that there was only ever one night king
in over the centuries he just created more and
more white walkers the way the legends talk about
the first long night is this character called the
last hero who defeats the night king and beats
them back to the lands of always winter but it
doesn't talk about them utterly destroying the
night king in the white walkers it just says
that they beat them back to the lands of always
winter in the frozen north so what they imply
happen is that they just use the dragonglass to
kill the whites that he created the other white
walker generals and before they were able to kill
him the night king with the dragonglass using it
in the same spot that the children of the force
used to create him that's what this is this is a
dragonglass dagger the nike retreated to the lands
always winter bite at his time and just slowly
replenished his forces through the bargains that
he made across hundreds of years with people like
craster who would come along over the centuries
if it wasn't clear craster in present day on the
game of thrones series formed a bargain with the
white walkers saying that he would offer them a
sacrifice of his children like the male children
which they would turn into new white walkers
implying that this has been happening
for centuries like there have been people
in the north that had formed bargains with
him before and that's one of the reasons why
you don't hear about the night king being super
active across those hundreds of years because
he'd form bargains along the way to replenish
his forces much more slowly as to not alert the
night's watch the only other recorded events
previously in the timeline before this are the
legend of the thirteenth lord commander who found
the white walker bride and was turned himself into
someone that they referred to as the knights king
plural night's king not the singular night king
eventually being defeated by the starks at the
time in the night's watch who are round thirteenth
lord commander implies that it was like a hundred
maybe a little bit more years after the creation
of the wall so it was still like many hundreds of
years ago i think what they imply in the books in
that period is that the lord commander at that
time was just turned into another white walker
like i said on the show they wanted to let you
know that there was only one night king at least
the way that they're presenting it that might be a
little bit different in the events of house of the
dragon they might try to recontextualize that but
until we see that we just have to assume that it
was only one night king for this entire thousand
years when they created the wall there were 19
castles total only 17 of them were filled at any
given time but like when they first created the
wall they were full of men by the time of aegon
the conqueror many many hundreds of years later
on the show there were about ten thousand men
manning the wall it was still a lesser amount
than they had started with but it was still a lot
of people because of aegon's prophecy obviously he
would have made that a big thing even throughout
the timeline like alessand targaryen jiharis's
wife the king before viserys actually spent a
lot of time visiting the wall with her dragon
so even as recently as the time of jiharis just a
little while ago they were still very preoccupied
with what was happening at the wall but after
robert's rebellion later in the timeline during
the events of the game of thrones series there are
only enough men to man three castles like that's
how much their forces have dwindled and most
of the realm has forgotten about the threat of
the white walkers like it's not until the pilot
episode till you actually see white walkers and
it's implied that they hadn't been very active
up to that point so during the events of house
of the dragon unless they throw us a big curveball
the white walkers the night king are very inactive
or just being very very quiet but they are still
there and now rhaenyra is probably gonna start to
be preoccupied with them but the whole idea with
what they're covering on house of the dragon the
dance of the dragons is that everybody becomes
way too preoccupied with the iron throne itself
and kind of descends into this real toxicity so
it's kind of implied that even though rainier for
instance might be preoccupied with the white
walkers on the side like that might be going
on in the background of her mind she might be
low-grade paranoid about that in the background
the targaryen civil war kind of causes everyone
to forget about what's really important and start
to focus on all the really bad stuff but even
though the show is meant to depict sort of the
beginning of the end of their family that doesn't
mean it's the end of people becoming kings inside
the targaryen family and knowing about the threat
of the white walkers in this song of ice and fire
so like i said you have kings come and go along
the way each one eventually learns about the
threat of the white walkers passes it on to his
air at any given time even though later in the
timeline you have a lot of rebellions like the
blackfire rebellion and many other crazy things
happen what probably happened in the future the
timeline though is that you do have people who
are heirs briefly or they sit on the iron throne
very briefly so more than a couple people at any
given time wind up learning about the prophecy but
they still keep it relatively secret until you get
to the time of the mad king rhaegar targaryen and
robert's rebellion that's when it's implied that
the prophecy was not passed on to the next king
it was until people like melisandre came back and
started talking about the coming long night and
then people like samwell inside the citadel who
found the prophecy written down like wait a minute
there's this weird prophecy in this dagger here
which is the same dagger the dragonglass dagger
that viserys was wearing legends of the long night
it's the same cat's paws valerian dagger
that arya later used to kill the night king
so i think the idea that the book that samwell
winds up reading from later in the timeline is the
same book that rhaenyra is reading from in this
trailer shot in the way that samwell explained
it is they basically found that in like a hidden
area of the citadel like it wasn't an area that
was accessed very frequently but hopefully that
explains what was going on with white walkers just
in general across the timeline like you have that
brief event with the knights king the 13th lord
commander but otherwise they're very quiet and
just forming bargains with craster-like people in
the north across time just taking their babies as
sacrifices i am really curious to see if they will
throw us a curveball and we'll see them on screen
during house of the dragon it would be a big
surprise because there is a lot of stuff during
the events that cover what happens at the wall
but it's always possible if you have any other big
questions about what's going on with white walkers
the night king during this period of the timeline
or the prophecy of the song of ice and fire just
write it below in the comments we'll get more
of this stuff in future episodes my full episode
3 video will post next sunday just like normal i
have a couple other bonus videos planned this week
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss that congratulations sophie
one you're the giveaway winner from my last big
house the dragon video everyone click here for
my full house the dragon episode 3 trailer video
in easter eggs and click here for my full episode
2 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!